hello everybody my name is Markiplier
and welcome to late night mop this is a
game by lexian the same Elixir who is
not here and about to Spring out of the
darkness and scare you no lunky's taking
over this one along with lunky's friends
hi
yeah no
nice to meet you
[Music]
anyway
it's good to be back and see another
game that lyxian has made and I've heard
that this one is inspired by more
cherries this decision which means that
it will be demonetized at any moment and
age restricted
all right I think we're okay actually
surprisingly so
oh also it's inspired by like
like power wash simulator but I think
also maybe in a tangential way visitor
Cleanup Detail which is a game that I
should play again
let's see this one
hey sorry for calling you so late but uh
would you mind going by the house and do
a quick clean up
oh yeah I made a bit of a mess and I
need the house cleaned as I have some
guests coming over in the morning okay
thank you
okay thanks where are you are you
sleeping in the house
oh interesting
well it's got the same punchiness that
Lucia normally had
pick up my hop eh
click to pick up Mom
this one is this some kind of a tutorial
I missed it do it again
I missed it oh wait
is that a face
is that a face hey
what are you
how'd you do that how'd you do that is
that a face I thought I saw a face door
is locked hmm what peculiar lighting
what strange non-ticking clock
what a box all right good great even
well
bam
Wham
excellent
well nothing spooky should happen here
I don't think there's much to expect wow
I'm behind the curtain
what
hmm
I keep thinking something's going to
happen and it
who's there
show yourself
all right fine
done I'm amazing
I'm incredible
I'm outstanding
hello
okay
doors locked sure it is
well so far not spooky
or at least not what I would call Spooky
maybe luxians lost his touch
baby Lucy's lost his touch hasn't even
been a jump scare in here
Nary is scared of jumping
this is almost pitiful
almost
but I guess I
I should give him the benefit of the
doubt and play it through I wouldn't
want to hurt his feelings
[Music]
oh yeah I gotta mop the carpet the
realism's a little off here
hmm
can't even pick up one I'm more more
than one item at it more than one item
at a time
nice
nice God damn I'm good
do I gotta mop the wall that's
disgusting
all right fine then well I better be
getting paid more for this because
seems like
seems like uh
seems pretty late to be cleaning also if
they're just upstairs and they have
guests guests coming over tomorrow
we get guests here today what did you do
what even happened here what is that
greatness
well
that's most of it
is it it's awfully foggy in here
well lyxian does like to smoke what a
weed
it was a little peculiar
you know I'd like to think that I know
lyxian's style at this point
and uh if I know anything about his
style it's jump scare jump scares and
more jump scares and you know it's
a little peculiar there aren't just like
a slew of cliche jump scares one after
another
strange
peculiar
foreign
[Music]
so that's how you're gonna play
that's what you're gonna do
well we'll see about that
oh my God it's trash Heap in here
it's almost like people don't actually
live here
almost like it's all a ruse
almost like it's all ruse
oh hey hey
hey
we don't know if that was anything at
all
sorry I sneezed I just sneezed real loud
guys I smell these real loud
apologize if I startled anyone
anyway back to the nice calm of this
game a nice relaxing Beauty
is this like a Portuguese thing hiding
all the keys to the other rooms in the
other rooms before it's like some kind
of a navigational maze
huh
well I don't know what I saw with that
but probably nothing
peekaboo I see you
well same the same old same old I don't
want to know how all these stains on the
carpet got here that is concerning that
is incredibly concerning Lexi and you
live uh in squalor I have to say
bye I'm assuming this is all part of
your Portuguese culture I don't know
your ways I couldn't possibly know your
ways but
judging by this representation I can
only assume that all Portuguese people
are just like this
and I
appreciate and respect your culture
is this offensive no I'm trying to be
accepting trying to be understanding
if this is how you are then this is this
is me
it's
beautiful
late night 11 am cleans and
whatnot
the chair
the mirror is it gonna flip down hmm
why are you blocking that whatever
I'm just gonna assume that I I got the
wrong call to the wrong place and
somehow I'm going to the wrong location
is that blood why can't I clean that
oh
[Music]
all right now we're talking
clean stain going behind the curtains
is someone back there
all right I'm gonna clean it
man it's a thick stain here
whoo good thing I got under those
candles
go Homa my mop my mop is gone
anyway good thing the candles were here
light my
it's fine
no
where my footsteps always out loud and
doubled
okay
okay
[Music]
I'm good
I'm good
I may okay about that one I think I'll
just go uh
[Music]
this is a trick
this is a trick Lexi and I see through
your ruse
you thought you ah you tried to make me
paranoid when in reality that is your
pasty white body that's lurking around
the corners it is nothing it is truly
nothing
laughs
[Applause]
um it might be a little too late to be
saying this but maybe don't go into my
house I uh I remember I kinda some
literally forgot about it anyways uh I
hope you're good and healthy and alive
okay bye
well
um
I had something in my throat
and
Ash just all it was man I never thank my
members thank you members you think
you're so cool like scene thank you my
members thank you my members here's a
list of every member I have and wow look
at them thank you thank you so much
gonna show me up you're gonna show me up
nah uh-uh lunky's got my back on that
one definitely wasn't a big ass to make
that happen I'm not saying my members
are better than your members I'm not
saying that very okay oh there's three
fast mopping oh hell yeah I'm going in
again I love New Game Plus oh I love
unlockables ah come on let's get
oh let's skipped
nope
all right
it really looks like a face I don't know
how that's done that's really impressive
that's pretty cool
nope all right fine
what do you got
all right I gotta get through this again
but how do I know I think I think nope
must be you hear the noise and you don't
go through the door
that has to be what that is
God damn I'm so fast oh my God
wonky put in some MLG music oh God
make it
make it hype
[Music]
done wow wasn't that in annoying you
know this game needs more trash cans I
need big arm mode I need to be able to
hold more trash
the replayability is starting to get
droll it's starting to get droll it's
starting to get droll the droll
it's droll
ah my God holy [ __ ] I think I might have
supposed to have been closer to that
beforehand oh my God
I mean it is nothing
okay hi now
the blood done
before what did I just see crawling
across the ground there did I just say
I saw something there I saw something
that's not something anyway time to go
home
nope nope
you're back
hey hey thank you so much for cleaning
the house I really appreciate it
although you did break a very special
and very expensive antique and left all
the pieces for me to clean so I'll be
deducting that from your payment
so yeah
thanks for that
when did where where did I win
when did I wait I mean
okay I bet I know what nope is
it's got to be somewhere where along the
first job you turn around and you go
away it's got to be that
oh nope uh-huh nope all right fine It's
gotta be after the first one or no
maybe after this one
no
maybe after you see the first thing then
then okay so far so fine oh man what a
good job what a fun job I have
what a fun job
I wonder if I can scooch ahead and get
it faster
oh God
well I'm out of here
later
gator
[Music]
are you
you
well well well glad to know I could
count on you to get the job done oh wait
you didn't
you made me look like a fool thanks a
lot oh and also you're fired
well I mean I didn't know that I was a
salaried kind of cleaner but
I think I quit I quit all right well
thank you so much for making this and uh
congratulations on this game it is very
scary that that last one did catch me
and one of them caught me but you know
not that much not that much so thank you
and uh thank you lunky
your friends for helping edit this
video
okay I'll uh
are you just gonna hang there if uh
usually I close these out alone
okay
right
the
wow